I get out of the way just to show you  the river knit here in Dumfries this is  the white sands area of Dumfries they're  expecting potentially the flooding here  to be worse than it has ever been the a  seven one three between here Dumfries  and air is already blocked due to  flooding this is where the flooding will  happen if it does across the other side  of the river from us  the waters have broken the banks this is  actually a car park you can see from the  bin probably risen of foot and a half  two feet the the situation has changed  here dramatically in the course of today  if you can see behind me I know a bit  dark now but those that fencing that you  can see is where I was broadcasting from  earlier and we've had to move locations  now because we were in danger of being  cut off by the river and just in the  short time we've been at this location  near the bridge I would put it at  probably another meter